less than a month after the military
took over his country in a coup in
february myanmar's ambassador to the un
spoke out in the general assembly in our
fight against the military regime ever
since the generals have wanted to fire
him and replace him with their own
ambassador
gulem isaac's i was appointed
afghanistan's ambassador to the un at
the end of july but less than four weeks
later the man who appointed him
president ashraf ghani had fled and the
government he represented had been
replaced the taliban want ambassador
izek zai to be replaced by one of their
spokesman suhail shaheen
the un general assembly has a
nine-member credentials committee which
must decide who should have the un seat
in both cases one of those members is
russia does it believe there should be a
change in representation
it's a very philosophic question i would
say
it's very difficult to answer yes or no
in this regard
russia of course prefers to interact
with those who represent their countries
who represent
their governments
kelly curry was one of the us's
ambassadors at the un during the trump
administration she's also a strident
advocate for human rights in myanmar she
told me her experience suggests the un
will try to delay any decision willful
moral blindness pervades the institution
at this point
you have a very weak secretary general
who's
not a strong leader who's not going to
push parties to make difficult decisions
and who
won't won't take the necessary
leadership to push the system out of its
current right so i think that a
continued stasis status quo that's
that pleases no one is the most likely
outcome yes
whatever the committee decides this is
not the end of the matter the committee
will come up with a report that then
goes to the entire un general assembly
james bays al jazeera of the united
nations